My next guest went from the private sector
as the CEO of Coca-Cola in Mexico,
to the public sector as the President of Mexico,
sounds familiar actually,
please welcome former president, Vicente Fox.
(audience applauds and cheers)
You brought me a gift, thank you so much.
These are boots.
There's writing on it.
No wall.
Thank you, thank you.
You’ve made it quite certain I will not be going back
to the United States.
Made in Mexico,
by the best--
Yeah, made in Mexico.
Yeah I would think so.
Have a seat, please, sir.
Of the world.
Thank you so much.
These are beautiful, and I will wear these often.
Yes, we have so much to talk about.
First of all, I get the sense that you have an opinion
about the wall.
Not just from the boots,
but from some of your very colorful Tweets
that you've sent out.
Your use of language crosses all barriers.
It's great.
Now, what's interesting,
let's talk about the history,
because you make an interesting point.
One of your opinions is,
throughout history, walls have not worked.
That is absolutely real.
We all remember when President Reagan came to Berlin,
he said, "Mr. Gorbachev, tear down off that wall."
No, no.
I was there.
He didn't say that.
(audience laughs)
Your history is good President Fox,
but it's not perfect.
But yes, the Berlin Wall famously failed.
It doesn't work.
Freedom, terror off.
Walls don't work.
And especially when we,
the people of United States, and Mexico,
we are neighbors, we're friends,
we're partners,
and most so, we're roommates.
We are so much together,
so many good friendship.
So many Mexicans doing a great work,
loyal to the United States.
Making that economy competitive.
And now they want to kick them in the ass,
and throw them out.
That's going to be a big, big loss for United States.
(audience cheers and applauds)
I live in Los Angeles, and I've said this before,
but you cannot walk three feet in Los Angeles
and not be made aware of
the incredible cultural contributions,
food, art, architecture,
that have been made by Mexicans.
And so it's very silly.
We are already together.
We are already together,
and that is not going to change.
Yes, sir.
And I was working in a ranch in Mexico,
and grew with campesinos at the ranch.
And I remember when there were tears in the eyes,
they will come and say, "Good bye.”
"We're moving North.”
"We're looking for opportunities.”
"We want to make some money to have a better life
for ourselves and for our family."
Good, loyal, loving, people.
They worked for the Bush family,
they worked for the Trump family.
They might not have documents,
but they know how to work.
They are decent.
They're honest.
And they contribute to the greatness of that nation.
So America is great,
(audience applauds and cheers)
and it will be greater because of our people right there.
There's been talk about why is Trump angry about Mexico,
there's a rumor that I've heard
that he had properties in Mexico,
and maybe there was some difficulties.
He tried to build one of his towers
in the Gulf of the Cortez,
which is in Baja.
It's a sanctuary of nature,
beautiful,
and he wanted to build one of his towers.
Of course, he was not allowed to.
It was prohibited.
And he got mad with Mexicans.
But maybe it has to do also with color.
You're quite white.
You're blonde.
What are you talking about?
I though I,
wait a minute,
I think I blend in quite nicely in this country.
I was in a telenovela, man.
Back off.
I sell cheese, dude.
But he doesn't seem to like the brown color.
And it's awful.
We Mexicans are "chiquitos pero picosos".
(audience applauds)
We might be short,
but we're hot like a jalapeno.
So don't mess around with us, Senior Trump.
Because if you look for it, you're going to find it.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Today, Rex Tillerson, the Secretary of State,
is visiting Mexico.
Do you think he's going to be proposing peace?
Is he bringing olive branch, in your opinion?
Today, they were playing around a game with the wall,
and Mexicans paying for the wall.
And they come with that instruction from Trump,
to try to convince us to pay for the wall.
Please, Mr. Trump, we're not paying for that wall.
That is very clear.
(audience cheers)
Can I just say one thing?
President Fox, I appreciate that you talking to Trump,
but I think he switched channels very early in this program.
(Conan laughs)
We very much wanted you to come on the show,
and give us your perspective.
Our mission here has been
to bring positivity and optimism,
and humanize the situation.
But I was very honored you took the time to fly down here--
May I give a little bit of advice to the guy?
Yeah, sure.
If he wants to negotiate,
we have to go for the whole enchilada.
Not just one piece.
Not just trading, not just security.
He has to learn that we are his best friends and partners.
You like some?
You know what I love about ...
(audience cheers and applauds)
You know what I really love about you, President Fox,
is that you use great visual aids,
to demonstrate.
(audience cheers and applauds)
President Vicente Fox everybody.
Much more Mexico when we return.